and how would you summarize why men are
in crisis no I think it's because in a
deep level the West has lost faith in
the idea of masculinity now that's no
different than the death of God it's the
same thing and so a Nietzsche knew what
the consequence of that would be I mean
that's most of what he wrote about you
know and so you'd say well the divine
symbol of masculinity has been
obliterated well so then what do you
expect what it what's gonna happen it's
gonna that means masculinity is going to
become weak and especially if the symbol
has also denigrated right which it
definitely is so what that means is that
the ideal that man could aspire to is
denigrated and well then with your ideal
in tatters you're weak that's that's
definitional so I think the reason that
men have been responding positively to
my my thinking let's say is that I don't
buy any of that I like the masculine
spirit it's necessary and it's not
fundamentally carnage and pillaging it's
not fundamentally rape culture you know
it's not fundamentally world destroying
and all of those things have been all of
those aspersions have been cast upon it
that's partly the guilt of Western
society for technological progress even
and those are reasonable challenges to
be set before men but they're not
reasonable accusations to swallow
without criticism what is a masculinity
we can aspire to well it's a
responsibility fundamentally and it's
it's it's to put it symbolically is that
your your responsibility is to incarnate
the Spirit of the logos that's your
responsibility that's your role in life
and that
is independent to some degree in whether
or not you accept the idea of a
transcendent and eternal reality now I'm
not making a case for that or against
that I those things are beyond human
understanding but we know what happens
if people act poorly if men act badly we
know what happens we know that the world
turns into something that's so close to
hell that the difference is trivial we
know that that's the story of the 20th
century so we should learn that lesson
and what that lesson is is pick up the
world on your shoulders and walk forward
pick up the world with all of its
trouble with all of its suffering with
all of its evil and move forward with it
and in bearing that burden learn that
you're the sort of creature that can
bear that burden and therefore deserving
of respect that's that's the that's
identification with the logos and that's
I don't I've never encountered an idea
that's better than that because it's not
it's so not naive it's the opposite of
naive it's like there's terrible evil
and there's terrible suffering it's
bottomless but the human spirit is
capable of voluntarily taking that on as
a challenge well it's worth a try yes
exactly that's that's that's that's the
positive meaning that's the positive
meaning that's the world affirming
meaning you know and that that's that
self-esteem let's say you know which is
very poorly characterized it's very
shallowly characterized because it
usually doesn't involve any sense of
responsibility but you know it's obvious
if you it's obvious in some ways if you
look at the people that other people
spontaneously respect
unless they've become unbelievably
cynical it's the people who adopt
responsibility and deal with it
competently so it's not a mystery that
that would be what you could aspire to
now it gets undermined if you feel that
that force of responsibility is the the
raping and pillaging patriarchal culture
that's despoiling the natural
environment and that's equivalent to a
cancer well you know no I don't buy that